[Music]
hello everybody welcome to generative
art svg and celestine uh before we start
if you'd like to follow along with any
code examples uh get a bra copy of the
slides as well as play with your own
celestine sandbox you can do that in
github.com uh slash red code final slash
raw crystal 2020 talk um just as well
too if you'd like to play around with
the um celestine docs and learn more
about how celestine works you can go to
docs.celestine and that'll set you up
with everything you need to know
all right so i'm ian i'm a web developer
at my own company uh that does web
development solvent uh i'm a generative
artist i really like crafting pretty
pictures especially ones that are
dynamic and have an animation in them
i'm a security dabbler so i really enjoy
playing around with chinese netcams
because they're just very insecure and
usually very poorly programmed oops
and i am the celestine author which
we're going to be talking about today so
before we start who does this talk for
uh anyone who's really interested in
making art if you think you're gonna be
good or bad you know generative art in
my opinion is kind of like the great
equalizer you don't have to be good at
drawing you the only thing you really
have to do is have some imagination and
the ability to program
anybody who's a web developer will gain
something out of this because we're
going to talk about svg and the svg
format can actually do a whole lot of
things um
which makes it very useful for web
developers who um maybe you know aren't
as happy with dealing with css
animations
uh
plotters charters and visualizers
anybody who's working with big or small
data of any kind svg has a lot of cool
features in it that can make it possible
to um
visualize your data in new and exciting
ways
and anybody who really enjoys just
taking an idea and turn it into a
product and getting that sense of
accomplishment um you'll hopefully enjoy
what we're gonna do today all right so
uh
what you should know you're gonna need
at least a basic knowledge of crystal if
you're rubyist coming in don't worry
there's nothing i'm gonna cover that is
outside the realm that crystal and ruby
share together
uh you're also going to need basic kamal
which is our version of sinatra very
simple just get root kind of stuff
and very basic html and svg you won't
need to know kamal or html or svg if you
just use the github project that i i
made includes a sandbox that's already
set up for you
so before we uh jump into the generative
art part of it let's talk about svg and
what it can do um because it's kind of a
standard that is a little bit um
i don't know muddled i guess and what it
can really do
uh it first of all it allows you to draw
really simple shapes essentially to a
canvas using xml tags so you use stuff
like path and circle and rectangle and
uh all of that contributes to your
overall picture on your canvas
um but the thing is that svg can
actually do a lot more than just draw a
couple pretty pictures and it turns out
that svg can make very complicated
animations in fact when i started this i
thought it was really could only be used
to make incredibly simple animations but
by the time i was done with it i found
out that there's stuff that you can do
with the animations in svg that um
is comparable to the kind of stuff you
could do with javascript
uh you can also use really incredibly
strong filters with uh svg it rasterizes
whatever vector stuff you have and
applies a filter to it and at first
again i thought these the filters were
incredibly simple but as i started to
learn more about it i learned that
there's some really strong ways you can
mix them to make very interesting
effects
and uh anybody who um
is a uh
uh who wants to put css or js into the
svg document you can do that so for
example if you're doing a um a website
right and you have a light mode and a
dark mode well you can structure your
svg so that way when you swap between
light and dark mode it uses the same css
colors and there you go you've got um
you know some basic interactivity in
that you can also hide javascript in it
so it's very interactive
oh
there we go all right and you can do all
that too with celestine it's a really
simple svg library for crystal it's i
wrote it as a domain specific language
so it's fairly simple you start off with
the celestine oops celestine draw method
that takes a block that takes a context
and that context has very simple things
that can get run on it rectangle circle
you can group items together all of that
jazz and the thing is is i also built
all the filtering and masking and
animation stuff that's in svg into
celestine so it should be fairly easy to
pick up and use
so let's talk about generative art
generative art refers to art that in
whole or in part has been created with
the use of an autonomous system so i've
got this uh picture right over here uh
this is called mind shift it's on my
website if you want to see a live
version of it but
the
crystal and celestine both work together
to make this image and animate it and
put all the features into it and the
thing about is that each time you run
this program with a different seed a
different number to input it or to input
with it will change the entire layout of
the picture you know it'll still look
very similar to this
but instead you know maybe it'll have
different colors the bridges will be in
different places the the windows will be
in different places there's a lot that
you can
do with generative art in terms of just
randomization and and making interesting
stuff
all right so let's talk about some
generative art techniques and a big one
is random numbers uh pretty much that's
like the backbone i would say of most
generative artists random numbers and
uh there's three different types that
essentially are most used in uh
generative art there's prng with stan
which stands for pseudo-random number
generator and it generates a random
number with an even distribution so
you're just as likely if you're asking
for a number between one and a hundred
to get one as you are to get ten
but what's cool about it is you can see
that to reroll the same random values so
if you liked the roles that you got uh
you can just remember the seed and
you'll get those same roles as long as
you use them in the same order
normal distribution works similar to
prng except instead of being even it
just
focuses essentially and tries to hit
close to the zero mark it you know it'll
deviate but for the most part it's gonna
you know it's you're very likely to get
a number between zero and point five
versus getting a number like three which
is you know really out there on the
chart there's also perlin noise which is
what we're going to be using and the
reason why perlin noise is so useful is
that it's a lot more iterative
or iterable than prng is and to explain
the problem if you use prng to generate
a piece of art right and if there's any
chance that um the prng isn't asked for
values in the same order or it uses
values out of order you'll end up with
an entirely different picture even
though you used
the same seed so
perlin noise makes that a lot easier
because it just uses coordinates and we
can iterate through coordinates a lot
easier but what it does is it returns a
value from float max to float min
and it tries to steer between the values
so it interpolates between the noise and
we'll uh we'll look at what this
actually looks like here in a second uh
this is the purlin noise chart i wrote
um it's fairly simple it's probably a
little busted in some ways but for the
most part it's going to work for what
we're going to do so we'll break it down
here first of all there's the dot noise
function that's uh what we just talked
about float min to float max it tries to
keep it around negative one to one but i
think there's some instances where it
can go out of bounds
there's also normalized noise which just
takes noise but it compacts it into a
space between zero and one which can
make things a little more useful for us
in certain aspects um there's also two
sibling methods that you can use off of
this int an item int lets you choose a
number between a min and a max and it uh
chooses that number based on the purl
and height so if you
use normalized noise at the zero
coordinate right and you get point five
out of it you're going to get 50 if you
ask for the same
coordinate using int with a min max of 0
to 100
there's also item which lets you pull an
item out in the same way so again it's
tied directly to the pearl and height
but sometimes you don't want things tied
to the pearl and height it might not be
exactly what you want so you might
actually want an even distribution of
numbers but you still might want to use
the coordinates from purl and noise
that's why i wrote these prng methods
essentially what it does is it takes the
coordinate and it plugs the value that's
at in it into a prng
and when it does this it sees the prng
and then it rolls one number and it's
done and so this gets you a fairly
random number every time you because you
just increase the seed by one and you're
pretty much set
um you can also use it with item as well
so you can pull a random item out of an
array
and uh there is one issue though with
doing this method and that is that all
the values if you use them on the same
iteration are all tied together so an
example bug would be like you build a
building generator right and the
generator generates a building color and
a building height well you find out that
all the buildings that are three high
are all red and all the buildings that
are four high are all green and you're
like why is this happening it's because
you accidentally tied all your values
together so to fix that i added a
secondary seed system which just moves
the
coordinate point that it's at and just
moves it just slightly over so it just
gets just a tiny bit different
of a number and it generates of course a
much more random even distribution that
way
all right so let's talk about the
process or how to you know make some art
and so i i broke down a uh a more
simpler version of mind shift because if
i had done the original version we were
going to be here all day talking about
that bridge how i did those bridges but
uh
this is this is fair fairly simple and
it also let me use a couple features
that i didn't get to use in the original
one
so let's jump on into it um so the setup
was i was on reddit and
i i'm gonna say this right now look for
to reddit and open processing and all
these other kind of art sites for
inspiration because there's a lot to be
taken from what other people have done
just truth be told and i was on red and
i saw this picture and i was like i love
this everything like there's there's
just so much i like about i like the
depth of it i like the colors i like how
it's simple but yet um you know i can
like look at it and i can identify
uh the
different steps i could take to make
this a piece of generative art you know
i can use perl and noise to make these
little chasms and um i can use prng to
choose where the windows go and stuff
like that so um
the other the other half of it too is i
was while i was on reddit i saw in the
comments somebody had said you know this
picture is super cool but the issue is
that it it would be way cooler if it was
animated and i was like i can i built
animation to celestine i can do that so
the first setup i do is i make some
color palettes and the way to do this is
you don't have to know any color theory
go online and check out this site called
coolers.co it is a
really simple site that just generates
color schemes for you like
it doesn't get really any simpler than
that
um the second thing i want to do is i
want to set up my secondary seeds in
advance because i know i'm going to need
them so i just put some values you know
for what i'm going to need for later and
i'll just use them as we go
so first step one we want to choose this
color scheme right because
that's probably the first thing we're
gonna want to do and to do that all we
use is just prng item to pull a
color out of or a color palette out of
our colors array and we pop in the seeds
for the for the colors and you just fill
a giant rectangle with that color easy
peasy uh not not too difficult so far
the next thing we want to do is make
what's called what i call the chasm mask
and uh to kind of explain how masking
works when you apply a mask to something
if the mask itself has white elements on
it
whatever is um you're applying the mask
to on those white elements shows through
but if there's black on the in the mask
it will basically punch a hole through
whatever you're masking so you can see
the stuff below it so we're going to
start by making a bunch of black
rectangles and we're going to align them
all pretty much in the center and we're
going to give them random widths right
then we want to apply a purlin the
purlin noise function to it so it makes
it nice and wavy but unfortunately when
we do this it's going to kind of look
unnatural so to fix that we apply a
little x-axis deviation and that uh
what's it called um
that jitters it a little bit to make it
look nicer
uh then all we need to do is just apply
it as a mask uh here we have the code to
actually make the mask you know you make
the stuff that you want to show through
white and the stuff you don't want to
show through black and then you just use
celestine to set the mask and easy peasy
not too hard
um so right now though looking at this
i'm like this is not really where i want
to be this is like like the most basic
idea of what i want but there's still a
lot of refinement that needs to be done
and unfortunately i can't really go too
in depth on how to do that kind of
refinement it's really more just about
visually playing around with the values
and finding what works for you
you know like some of the challenges i
had was stuff like i tried to use
a single formula to describe all the
levels and the problem is is that it
wasn't producing the values i wanted so
to make things a little simpler i um
i made it so that way uh each layer has
its own data essentially on how big the
rectangle should be to make the chasm
mask um how big uh or how how far you
should you deviate with the pearl and
noise and stuff like that and we just
make sure that the chasm gets smaller um
as we go further back so we can see the
stuff at the back if that makes sense
so next we want to animate it and this
is really easy using celestine you just
use the animate motion method on any
drawable that you want to animate and
what we're going to do is we're going to
draw a path okay using very simple
turtle commands and it's going to start
in the upper
left-hand corner and it's going to go up
to the negative screen height and this
moves our layer up right but when we do
this there's going to be a seam on the
bottom that's going to show and then
eventually the layer is going to get
entirely out of frame and then it's
going to snap back so to make this
more seamless what we're going to do is
we're going to take an exact copy of the
layer and we're going to put it down
below it on the y-axis so as the layer
comes up it's got this other layer
behind it and then when the animation
ends it snaps back and the user doesn't
even see that there was a seam or an
animation change
and uh you just make the
duration of the animation longer the
farther you go back so that creates that
parallax scrolling effect like you're
going down the chasm
uh this is the code to do it fairly
simple run dot animate motion on it um
title tie the level to the duration so
it makes a uh it makes it longer the
farther back it is and
then um just draw your path and draw
your copy underneath it and there you go
easy peasy so the last thing we're going
to do is filters and uh for this i
really wanted to create a depth of field
kind of uh effect and how that works is
that this whatever you're focusing on is
going to be not blurry but then whatever
um is closer or farther away from the
point you're focusing on is going to be
blurry so in this case i want to focus
all the way back to the last layer and
all you do is you just define a filter
for each layer using the blur filter in
svg
and you just make the blur amount more
the closer you are and you got easy
peasy dof
this is all the code that's necessary to
do it you
pop in some filters uh make four four
filters essentially change the deviation
to be exactly
tied to the level and then just set the
filter and you're done there you go um
here's a couple just examples with some
different color palettes hopefully the
blur kind of comes through it might not
come through as great in the the zoom
call but uh it's there i promise you
and yeah that's it that's all i got so
if you liked what what i had to say
today check out my github at github.com
redcodefinal if you're interested in
doing some business with me or buying
some art or something hit me up at ian
sullivan
however if you want to email me about
your crystal project i would love to
hear it and i'd love to network with you
so email me about your thing at ian at
0x4242 4242.in
and also celestine is at github.com
celestine cr celestine and the docs and
that's it so let's jump into the q a
here
oh all right thank you very much ian
oh cheers let's see
posh there we go
is anyone
i don't see anything in q a but maybe on
the chat you can drop yeah let me check
yeah let me check discord real quick i
didn't i didn't hop into that yet
oh here we go
nope it doesn't look like there's any uh
what's it called
it doesn't look like there's any q a so
i think we're all set oh never mind hold
on uh can you tell me something about
how your crystal code maps to raw svg
particularly animation stuff yeah okay
so this is this is fairly simple um let
me actually
share my screen again here
okay um
all right let's go to saw.vin
here real quick i'm just going to open
one up um yes you can do bitmap effects
with celestine anonymous attendee
uh
okay let me just go
inspect element here
i'm just going to go grab the image here
we go
we'll see
oops
all right um so this is a uh
this is the breakdown of of what one of
these files actually looks like
and um
the animation part of it let's see if i
can find it i think it's all the way at
the bottom here the animation part of it
is going to be right around here here we
go so how it works is it just wraps um
you just wrap whatever
uh
thing you want to animate inside tags um
so for example here we're gonna we're
gonna animate a group um and we just use
the animate motion it includes a path
etc and it pretty much maps fairly
straightforward to um how you would
write it in crystal i guess if that
makes any sense
uh let's see how did i get into
interactive art um
i was really bored
i think it's the best way to describe i
was really bored and i really like open
processing and i was like i want to do
open processing sometimes so i started
playing around with that and i got kind
of into it and then i got to a point
where i was like i don't really like the
language processing um is built upon so
i'd much rather
uh yeah sorry
i'm sorry what's up yep we are seeing
your presentation
oh you're still seeing my presentation
oh i'm sorry about that
what the heck why did it
you share hold on i don't know why i did
that oh there we go sorry about that
there we go um so here this is the uh
this is the breakdown of how it looks
this is the animate motion sorry i guess
i didn't i didn't do that right but um
you just wrap your whatever item you
want to move
um in or
you you ma wrap the animate motion tag
in whatever item you want to move and it
will
handle it for the most part
um is it possible to embed celestine
rendered output in a larger html page
using something like ecr absolutely yes
you just uh you just use
celestine.draw like how you normally
would you can also um
use celestine.draw with an i o so if you
have some sort of an i o system that
you're using to build your rendered html
output it's just as easy as using the i
o in draw
but yeah i think that about covers it
any more questions anybody got any more
stuff
all right cool
well thanks for thanks for listening i
hope you guys enjoyed it kevin kevin
asked uh how did you get into
interactive art oh yeah i thought i
thought i answered that i said that um i
uh i
really what what happened was i was
really bored and i just started like
looking around on the internet for like
programming projects that might interest
me and i ended up coming across open
processing and i played around with
processing.js a bit but i don't like
javascript very much to be honest so i
uh you know wanted to use stuff that you
could do in processing and crystal but
there wasn't really a good method to do
that so i ended up kind of jumping into
the svg format for it
all right great
so oh there's one more
oh one more question let's see q a here
we go um do you recommend any
mathematical areas that'd be helpful for
doing interactive art um
yeah uh i would say there's there's a
couple
um big
things that
you know are really common in generative
art and one of them is fractals fractals
are probably like the
like most interesting thing in uh
generative art there's just so much you
can do with them and there's um
they're just really just intensely
interesting because they just go on
forever pretty much
um let's see what else flow fields are
another good one too a lot of people do
a lot of generative art stuff with flow
fields uh purlin noise is another
excellent place to start if you um
you know want to learn how it actually
works because i'll tell you i don't i
don't know i wrote the gem and or i
wrote the shard and i just translated it
from somebody's ruby code so i couldn't
tell you how perlin noise really works
on a real level
all right
i think we're all set
okay hey thanks a lot for letting me
do my talk